لقد كانت الجزائر صبورًا بشكل غير عادي
في مواجهة
جميع الأعمال التي
ارتكبتها المملكة المغربية ضد
سيادة الجزائر ضد وحدة
الوحدة الوطنية الجزائرية والعديد من
الإجراءات المفتوحة والمغطاة الموجهة ضد
سيادة بلدنا وهذا هو السبب في
أننا نعتقد أن  إن اتخاذ مثل هذا القرار
كان بمثابة إرسال الرسالة الصحيحة إلى
حكومة المغرب مفادها أننا لا
نستطيع قبول المزيد من مثل هذا
السلوك من جانب بلد مجاور ،
لذا فهذه طريقة حضارية
لوضع حد لوضع لا يمكن
أن يستمر.  بعد الآن دون
المخاطرة بتكبد المزيد من الضحايا والدفع
بالبلدين إلى
مسار غير مرغوب فيه ،
فكيف تكون هذه طريقة حضارية للتعامل مع
هذه التوترات ، السفير لامامرا ،
فهذه مشاكل عمرها عقود ولكن
عندما تقرر التخلص تمامًا  من أي
نوع من العلاقات الدبلوماسية كيف تكون هذه
الطريقة المتحضرة للتعامل مع
الصراع سيدي
أعتقد أن هذه طريقة حضارية
لأننا كنا ننتظر من
الحكومة المغربية توضيح
عدد من القضايا أه التي كانت
تدخلا واضحا في شؤوننا الداخلية
التي كانت محاولة لتقسيم
الشعب الجزائري وخلق
حالة من شأنها أن تزعزع الاستقرار
ليس فقط للجزائر بل للجزائر كلها
منطقة شمال إفريقيا لذلك
لم تأت التأكيدات والتوضيحات
من قادة المغرب
وبالتالي
كان على الحكومة الجزائرية اتخاذ قرار سيادي
وهذا هو اتخاذ قرار
وهو وسيلة للتذكير بأن هناك
التزامات في الحياة  من
الدول المجاورة هناك عدد من
المبادئ الأساسية للقانون الدولي هناك
علاقات جوار تحتاج أيضًا إلى
الالتزام
بها وبدون مثل هذا
الوضع لا يوجد سبب
لاستمرار البلدين في
إقامة علاقات دبلوماسية والإشارة إلى
أن الوضع طبيعي  بينما من
الواضح أنه غير طبيعي ويجب
أن ينتهي على أي حال